Hellenic office a volunteer with the
German action reconciliation service for
peace nearly every day she takes
visitors through the ruins of
oradour-sur-glane filling them about the
day when members of the waffen-ss
massacred almost all of the residents
and then torched the village
642 men women and children died the
ruins stand as silent witness to the
massacre 18 year old Helena cough is
deeply moved every time it's a journey
into the past for me it's more raged
that I feel it's more in comprehension
it's simply incomprehensible for me it's
because I can't explain it that I feel
this grief archive footage shows street
scenes in Arad or in the summer of 1944
shortly before the massacre people seem
to be enjoying the summer weather aware
that Allied forces are advancing through
France and forcing the German army to
retreat the 10th of June started no
differently
that was the day general Heinz Lama Dean
ordered units of the waffen-ss division
disguise into hola Dora
robear Abe Rana will never forget what
happened nineteen years old at the time
he was standing on this spot on the Main
Street they found the SS entered the
village from back there and took up
position there then an SS man walked
down each side of the street drumming
the people out of their houses and
giving orders and everyone followed them
give ya a good the SS herded the
villagers together and separated the men
from the women and children they were
allegedly searching for hidden weapons
robbery abraha recounts that he was
taken to a neighbor's barn with 40 other
men they set up two machine guns here
most of us were standing here in the
middle of the pond I was standing back
there by the wall then all at once there
was a loud bang and they started
shooting the wounded to a bra was
wounded he lay motionless under the
bodies of his friends and neighbors
pretending to be dead then the soldiers
set fire to the barn to keep or they
threw everything that was flammable on
top of us eventually the fire reached me
as well then I had the choice of being
burned alive or dying from a bullet I
have no way to escape but then at last
they pulled out some food of our heart
Gobert Umbra was just one of six people
to survive the oradour massacre general
jean de Gaulle visited the remains of
the village in March 1945
deeply moved he declared that the ruins
were to be preserved as a memorial to
Nazi terror the massacre haunts France
to this day after the war German
politicians were long barred from
entering oradour only in recent years
have German volunteers like Alena cough
begun to work for the Memorial Center
assisting French historians or giving
tours to French school children it's now
a part of the oradour Museum concept for
Germans to take part I think it's good
the Germans come here to work they're
not our enemies anymore and times have
changed the Germans from back then are
no longer the Germans of today the
mentality is completely different the
archive too is the scene of German
French teamwork many details of the
massacre remained unclear Alena caulk
often accompanies French historians as
they collect material in the region and
interview surviving eyewitnesses I think
this would be very hard for me to cope
with and that's what I admire about the
people we talked to they relive the
whole thing over and over when they talk
about it the images return komyoji
videos on video
she met Wilbur a bra for the first time
a short while ago she's accompanied him
several times to the ruins since today
they're visiting or adores former church
robear a bra needs some time alone here
this is where the SS murdered all the
women and children the bullet holes are
still visible in the walls and altar
among the victims were his mother and
sister Olga the bottle I look around and
wonder how they died
where did they lie at which spot that's
the question that keeps going through my
mind I'm not that good where did they
die is there any way he can forgive yes
I can forgive the Germans but never the
ones responsible for this the ones who
did this in spite of what he experienced
robbery bra has spent decades working
for reconciliation but he says the
future of franco-german friendship lies
with young people like Alina
you